They want the terrorists to win. They want the Islamic extremist
to win. And so what they do is they try to downplay their bad
actions. >> Shut your brain off now. They support terrorists.
They support terrorists. They hate America. They say death to
America. They hate us all. They want us all dead. Cuz you're
acting like you actually think that that's a problem. But you
don't think that's a problem. You're not even close to thinking
that's a problem. You're just feeding out slop. This is just
cattle feed you're spreading around.
I think I'm going to go to the the best friend clips, the Hasan
40,000
Cuz it's very funny. People were getting very angry about these
clips. This was the clip that Lunar Box was reacting to earlier
today. Hasan abi crashes out on a chatter after saying they killed
40,000 people Hasan during the Iran
Okay, 40,000. This magically transforming number has become 40,000.
Very cool. Okay, no, they didn't. Well, listen, this guy kind
of yapped into killed 40,000 people, man. No, they
No, they didn't. You're a god damn idiot if you think that, okay?
You're a [__] I'm sorry. They did not kill 40,000
people, dumbass. They did kill a ton of people in the process
of of uh suppressing the the protest that that took place. Which
by the way, America Israel openly admit that they played a role
in, okay? But they did not kill 40,000 people in 2 days. Like
you're you're unbelievably dense. You have convinced yourself
It doesn't even It doesn't even matter. Like them killing 10
people is still [__] up, okay? I've never heard a
consistent number on this from people. They just turn around
and say, "Oh, they killed, you know, 80,000 people." I've heard
80,000, 50,000.
Ridiculous. Shut up. Mm. Jesus Christ, how Totally reprehensible
to crack down on protests in your country through violence, to
kill a whole bunch of protesters, okay? But yes, it is not even
close to 40,000.
Why is he arguing like that? Dot dot dot. Why is he arguing like
that? How do you want him to argue it, Jorge? How would you
If you knew for a fact that that number is totally fabricated,
how would you argue this? That the reason that that number is
being trotted out and being used is to manufacture consent for
the war right now. That realistically, that's like BB's That's
like Bibi Netanyahu's wet dream. Is he If he could get more Iranian
civilians killed, he's going to try to do that. Cuz it is totally
made up. And people are just going to seize on whatever they
can, whatever little edge they can to try to criticize this guy.
It's just
How do you not recognize that it's like this is propaganda
to actually justify American and Israeli intervention.
That's what you're leaning into. Yeah, it is literally propaganda.
By the way, it's totally disingenuous propaganda when you have
the Stone Age tweets. When this tweet exists, back to the Stone
Age. These people never once cared about the people of Iran.
They didn't want to liberate them ever. This was never a concern.
Never something they wanted to do. Yes, but that 40,000 number
was used, well, the 30,000 number was originally used to say
they're an evil regime that's cracking down on protesters and
we have to help them. And then it comes out in the news. You
all find out it comes out in the news that Israel has every idea.
They understand perfectly that there is no chance for this protest
to work, right? There's no chance for anything to work after
they start bombing. And they still argue for people to come out
in the streets. That there is no hope that they are going to
get gunned down and Israel knows this and are still advocating,
"Hey, come out in the streets. Come on, protest. Seize back your
government." And you're willing to just trot out this number.
It feels stupid disingenuous. It feels actually, frankly, pretty
disgusting to me.
That you do this. I saw Best Friend just uploaded some Asmongold
reaction to this, which is why I wanted to actually cover it.
I want to see what Asmongold has to say. Look, at the end of
the day, I agree with you. Radicalism of any sort is bad, which
is why this magical >> 40,000 people, man. No, they didn't.
No, didn't. You're a god damn idiot if you think that, okay?
You're a [__] I'm sorry. They did not kill 40,000
people, dumbass. They did kill a ton of people in the process
of of How do you know?
Like I I don't even understand this.
Cuz some of us actually look at the organizations who track this
kind of Some of us actually care to have some accurate facts
that can back their
Just saying. I'm just saying some people actually go and look
this stuff up. Some people do actually care. What do you mean
how do you know? What do you mean how do you know? Suppressing
the the I mean, why do you think they turned off the internet?
Like I mean, really, think about it for 3 They turned off the
internet and then broadcast on their own broadcast network the
corpses in the hospitals. They were explicitly cracking down
and explicitly going, "Guess what? If you're out protesting,
you're going to get shot in the face."
They shut the internet off to further to further chill the protests.
Obviously. Yeah, they're not good people. They're not good people.
Show us those videos. I've not seen those videos. I've only seen
Dropsite reporting on those videos. But considering it's Dropsite
reporting on the crimes of the Iranian regime, I do find it to
be somewhat credible. Like it's not something that confirms their
biases. That, you know, people Dropsite being to me the most
the most credible or well-known anti-Israel, like anti-Zionist
reporting network. Right? So this isn't confirming their biases.
If they were confirming their biases, I would go, "Oh, well,
now I need a different source." But for this one, I I do tend
to think it's fairly
3 sec Why would they turn off the internet if they weren't going
to kill a bunch of people?
Protest that that They did kill a bunch of He just said they
were He just said they killed a bunch people. What?
He literally just said they killed a bunch people. It took place.
Which by the way, America Israel openly admit Just show us. I
mean, I have to I'd have to go find the video. I watched it back
in February.
I It would take me a minute to find it. >> a role in, okay?
Trying to assign ownership of the protests against the government
that's literally by his own admission systematically killing
their own people, then assigning ownership of it to Israel and
uh America. No, maybe yeah, maybe Israel and America helped because
they thought that it's bad to kill your own protesters
Oh, no. Look, at the end of the day, I agree with you. Radicalism
of any sort is bad, which is why this magical >> people,
man. No, they didn't. No, they didn't. You're a god damn idiot
if you think that, okay? You're a [__] I'm sorry.
They did not kill 40,000 people, dumbass. They did kill a ton
of people in the process of of How do you know?
Like I I don't even understand this. Uh suppressing the the I
mean, why do you think they turned off the internet? Like I mean,
really, think about it for 3 sec Why would they turn off the
internet if they weren't going to kill a bunch of
Protest that that took place. Which by the way, America Israel
openly admit that they played a role in, okay? Trying to assign
ownership of the protests against the government that's literally
by his own admission systematically killing their own people,
then assigning ownership of it to Israel and uh America. No,
maybe yeah, maybe Israel and America helped because they thought
that it's bad to kill your own protesters just because they want
to change the government.
The people aren't doing
Maybe Maybe like America and Israel had really good intentions.
Maybe Israel and America had really, really, really good intentions,
guys, the whole time. Maybe they're actually like the good guys.
What I think happened is they they shut the internet off internet
off for two reasons. One, they don't want videos of them killing
people. Yes. Two, they don't want people communicating. I'm guessing
they shut off a bunch of ways to communicate in the country,
right? If there is some sort of like manufactured
uprising happening, which I believe they they thought this.
Okay, you don't want these people to be able to communicate and
trade information in the country.
And then three,
Nah, I don't even know that there's a three. That's probably
number two, okay? Oh, three, it was also to to make it seem like,
yeah, we're we're going to be doing crimes on you. We're going
to be cracking down and killing people. They want to chill the
protests as well.
>> doing anything wrong. He just justified mass murder
of civilians because of Israel. As I've said before, Hasan will
always fall off on the side of defending, rationalizing,
justifying,
and downplaying Islamic terrorism.
He will always do this.
Uh-huh. I would say more in this case.
He's not justifying. He's not saying it's okay. He He literally
said it was bad. Did he not say it was bad?
I'm pretty sure he said it was bad and they killed a bunch of
people. They just didn't kill 40,000.
Every single time. Where's the justification?
It's bad, but Israel and US Listen to the way he says it. He's
saying the US and and Israel played a part. He is adding that
in because he thinks it's important context to have. He's not
saying they're responsible. He's saying they played a part in
the uprising, which they almost certainly
That is That is documented on the record. Okay? That BB went
to Trump in January and said, "Hey, we can cause an uprising
in this country. We just want you to know we could foment uprising
in this country. Maybe even before January. Right? Like we can
use this to foment further uprising. And then the Shah does his
little call to action that people are going out in the streets
and rioting on. Is that not Is there nothing there? Is that not
like a thing we could No? 3,000 people in 2 days. Like you're
you're unbelievably dense. You have It was 3 days, idiot. It
was 3 days. It It It them 3 days to do that. Convinced yourself.
It doesn't even It doesn't Wait, does he think 40,000 people
died in 3 days?
Does Hasan believe that? Doesn't even matter like them killing
10 people It doesn't even matter. Still [__] up.
Yeah? Okay. He's trying so hard to make it worse. No way. It
doesn't even matter because
even 10 people dying would be sad. And he like pauses, "It doesn't
even matter." Good one. It's actually It's so funny because that
is the exact same sentiment exact same way of speaking that Hasan
did for the Well, it doesn't matter in the wake of a genocide
or around a genocide. They don't do anything about the claim
of genocide. And Hasan here goes, "Well, it doesn't matter if
that many people got killed. It would be bad if 10 people got
killed. It's still like heinous."
I've never heard a consistent number on this from people. They
just turn around and say, "Oh, they killed, you know, 80,000
people." I've heard 80,000, 50,000, 40,000. It's [__]
ridiculous. Shut up.
Jesus Christ, how do you not recognize it? It's like this is
propaganda
to actually justify American and Israeli intervention.
But, there's no propaganda about Palestine. The amount of people
that were killed in Palestine is a defined number that nobody
can ever question. But, you can totally question it. I would
just ask why you would question it over like the Israeli government
accepted numbers. Which by the way come from the Palestinian
the Gaza Health Authority the Gaza Health Ministry.
The numbers they accept are the Gaza Health Ministry's numbers.
So, you try to do this equivocation that makes no sense at all.
Okay? But, it does literally it's not the same. It's not even
remotely the same. Everybody involved agrees on those numbers
for the Gaza death totals. Or they agree on a range that we use.
The problem here is nobody agrees on the range. But, whenever
Iran intentionally takes off the internet, they shut down the
entire internet, they bust in Iraqi militia forces, and there
are leaked videos of people being massacred in the streets, then
no, actually well, we don't know how many guys. It would There's
no way it was that many. Oh my god.
That's what you're leaning into.
And also, do you want to know why people originally said it was
10,000?
I already I've already said, Mike Louis, when I when I pointed
this out that it's like disingenuous to be more contextualization
you do here. So, I I have no idea what the what do you call it?
The actual civilian death total is. That was the number I got
from AI and I I literally said, maybe not on the stream, but
definitely when I posted that originally in my Discord that those
numbers are like not valid like not
I didn't I didn't spend any time looking them up.
But still, I would say even if you even if you doubled the Russian
numbers, tripled them, quadrupled them, I don't think it's getting
that much higher. Because it went up. And so, it's like, "Well,
last year he said he was 40 years old. This year he says he's
41. Which one is it? He's lying. He He's got to be lying. Why
is he giving us different answers?" Oh my god. No, this is it.
And again, Hasan will always fall off on the side of justifying,
making excuses for, and sometimes even passively supporting Islamic
terrorism like he did with the Houthis. And also like he did
with Hamas. So, really
But, it's way different than how he did with the Houthis. With
the Houthis, he just said, "I stand with the Houthis. I I stand
10 toes down with the Houthis." That is justifying. That is saying
it's okay. That is like something you could actually criticize.
That's not what he's doing here. He's not standing with them.
He's not going, "I stand 10 toes down with the Ayatollah." Why
are we comparing the
Billy, that's what you can expect from somebody like Hasan. And
this will always be the case. And again, you can take this to
the bank. And other people like him will do the exact same thing.
Every single time they will do this.
And Hezbollah, yes, falls on the side of terrorism every single
time. It's because they're terrorist supporters. That's the reason
why. It's literally that simple. They want the terrorists to
win. They want the Islamic extremists to win. And so, what they
do is they try to downplay their bad actions and then over
total not termination. Just no, we can't
What are you Are you trying to have a thought there? Are you
trying to like think about something? Are you trying to think
anything about this? Right? You're trying to Are you trying to
use your brain? No, no, no, no, no. Shut your brain off. They
support terrorists. They support terrorists. They support terrorists.
Shut your brain off now. They support terrorists. They support
terrorists. They hate America. They say death to America. They
hate us all. They want us all dead.
Okay. All right. Well,
Hasan trying to lull his cattle back to sleep. Okay. Go No, no,
no. Don't go awakening. No no go awakening here. Okay? Go back
to sleep. Go back to
They're not doing it, Hasan. Nobody's going back to sleep. Play
the bad actions of people that are against them. That's what
they do. It's It's I mean, obviously. I mean, duh. Like how do
you passively Well, yeah. I mean, by not going after them and
not bringing these things up. So, yeah, that's it. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Hasan handing out the
if that's not a That that might be a thing we have to continue
going forward,
I don't know if he gets it correctly. I'm going to do the full
segment the full Hasan segment before we watch any of this other
responses, okay? Hasan [__] might not be a household
name at least among adults. But, ask your kids. His new role
as a midterm surrogate for some Democrats is proof that his political
influence is expanding far beyond the streaming platform Twitch
where he has taken up residence. He is without question an online
influencer with nearly 3 million followers. His rise as a prominent
voice on the left is now driving a wedge between Democrats and
for good reason. By the way, I just want to remind you guys really
quickly, okay? Just really quickly. I just want to remind you
all. Hasan is bad. But also,
if you criticize Hasan by saying he loves China too much, he
is way too sympathetic to China. I've never once pushed back
against that criticism, okay? Or at least I haven't in years,
basically. I don't push back against that criticism.
Right? You can do all these criticisms of Hasan. You can say
things about him that I won't I won't at all say, "No, you're
wrong."
But, the things people go after Hasan for are not things that
are true. They're things that are essentially fabricated. And
it just upsets me, okay? The sloppiness upsets me.
It's very goofy. Hasan Piker's past and present is checkered
with controversial if not outrageous if not
bigoted state comments like this one. America deserved 9/11,
dude. I'm saying it. We totally put it on ourselves, dude. Holy
[__] The ultra-Orthodox leaving is I I don't understand
why they always use the 9/11 one. I don't because you can easily
make an argument that American interventionism caused radicalization
in the Middle East, which is what he's Oh, no.
Hasan He's doing my job for me. Hasan No, Hasan. That's my job.
What the [__] saying. Like I feel like there's like
50 other clips that are worse than that. Yeah. Like that's just
my opinion.
If they serve in the military and then they get their untrained
inbred asses shipped into Southern Lebanon. Oh, I remember this.
Again.
Again, very funny.
Uh-huh. Yeah, it's Hasan [__] calling Orthodox inbred.
[__] has also posted comments such as these where
he unequivocally sides with Hamas calling them the lesser of
two Israel's compared to the
>> These where he unequivocally sides with
Well, he isn't wrong. They are inbred. Dude, no way. Well, he
isn't wrong.
>> The lesser of two Israel's compared to the government
kind of based. [laughter] Oh, no. Where he unequivocally sides
with Hamas calling them the lesser of two Israel's compared to
the government
lesser of two evils compared to the government of Israel. [__]
has since apologized for his comments on 9/11, but he stood by
the rest. He's accusing others of taking him out of context.
In a Wall Street Journal op-ed, the leaders of the Democratic
think tank Third Way write, "Mr. [__] is anti-American,
anti-women, anti-Western, and anti-Semitic. No Democrat should
engage with him. All should seek to push him to the fringe where
he belongs." Unquote. I mean, anybody who anybody who does anything
to try to like kind of minimize or delegitimize
criticism of or promote or provide any sort of you know, like
help to you know, any of these terrorist groups, right? The Houthis,
Hamas, Iran as a country.
You know, listen. I'll give you this. I'll give you this entirely.
You can have Hasan. All I want is for you to admit that the IDF
is a terrorist group and we should do the exact same thing to
anybody who supported them. That's all. That's it. Okay? As long
as we if we make that agreement, let's
I think Hasan will be the first to volunteer. Hasan will be like,
"Yes. Yes, destroy my career. As long as you destroy all of those
other people, too. Thank you so much. Thank you so much."
really is is obviously anti-woman and anti-Semitic. I mean, really.
I mean, cuz these people Hamas doesn't want to kill Israel kill
people in Israel. They want to kill all that Houthis have it.
It's literally in like their flag or like their their like mission
like you know, like your mission statement as a company. Well,
their mission statement says they want to curse all the I mean,
it doesn't say all the Israelis. It says all the So, I mean,
it's just it's just categorically true.
And that's a problem?
That's a problem for you. Who are the people Asmongold aligns
with again? That would be Myron Gaines, Sneako, Nick Fuentes.
What do they say Asmongold?
What do they say? Do they say Israel or do they say the
Cuz you're acting like you actually think that that's a problem,
but you don't think that's a problem. You're not even close to
thinking that's a problem. You're just feeding out slop, okay?
This is This is just cattle feed you're spreading around. That's
it. You're just spreading around cattle feed cuz you're trying
to make sure that they all understand you should hate Hasan.
But you don't actually hold any of these principles that you're
even You don't hold these principles at all that you're espousing
currently. Oh, it's really bad to say it's the Jews and not just
say Israel. You don't think
Hasan [__] And they they they kill them, too. Like
it's not like this is some person with opinions. I mean, they
Ah, he caught himself. He caught himself. He realized that oh,
I actually support a bunch of people who do say it's the Jews.
So, I need to make sure that it's Well, they actually have killed
Jews. Oh, they actually I need to
For the Hamas people, I understand a little bit the Hamas people,
okay? I
But here's the thing. If you want to make it
This is what nobody gets, okay? If these people want to go well,
actually October 7th is just Sorry, the Gaza war is justified
because of October 7th.
That works
recursively the whole way down the stack, okay?
That means that if you if you say Octo- the the dead in Gaza
are okay because of October 7th or acceptable because of October
7th, you must automatically say October 7th was okay because
of the previous atrocities visited upon the
If you're going to play that game, you play that game recursively
the whole way down the stack.
Do not say October 7th was a tragedy and not say what's happening
now is a tragedy, okay? who also killed them. Recently become
an issue in Michigan. It's a highly competitive three-way Democratic
primary for governor, Dr. Abdul Sayed, one of the three candidates
and a former CNN commentator, announced that [__]
will join him for two rallies in April. His opponents quickly
seized on that, slamming the decision as unacceptable, calling
[__] not somebody that you should be campaigning
with. Well, the reason why they're probably doing this There
is a coalition of people that will try to make excuses for allow
and then create inroads for Islamic radical extremism. And I
think that Hasan does this. Like there will never be a time where
Hasan will side with America against radical Islam. This will
never happen. And the odds are that this other guy is the exact
same. That's the reason
Well, I think So, hold on.
I I mean, I can almost agree with something like that. I think
Hasan will say because he is somebody who is like culturally
Muslim, not unlike Stardust, all right? I think what he could
do is see the like empath- He could empathize with the people
who are painted with that brush, who don't have those beliefs,
and he wants to get a word in for them. You'd think Asmongold
would understand because of how Tipsout basically came out and
said it was really up for Asmongold to speak about his culture
and his people the way he did. You think Asmongold would feel
a little more empathy for the Tipsout guy. Even when Asmongold
came out and said, "Oh, I apologize. I'm sorry that I did this.
I'm sorry I made you feel this way. I'm going to clean up my
room and be a better person." And then he immediately went back
to being like Muslims,
Arabs.
hate Arabs.
Within 2 seconds, okay?
Pretty embarrassing, to be honest with you. why they're doing
it. It's actually that simple. And as soon as you like And again,
if you don't believe what I'm
look in the past
and wait in the future.
And it will be proven every single time. moment when there was
clearly a lot of pain and trauma across our state. Ardonis Sullivan
caught up with [__] over the weekend at a No Kings
rally in New York and asked how he felt about the Democratic
Party's future. You have become uh You have become an issue within
the Democratic Party yourself. Tell us about that. I don't think
I'm necessarily an issue within the Democratic Party as much
as uh I am an issue for a lot of consultants. I don't want fascism
to win in this country. I don't want Republicans to win in this
country. We can argue on the methods. Maybe you think that uh
my world view and my values and and the policies that I want
politicians to represent might be different than yours, but at
the end of the day, I think we have the same goals.
I should note that I misspoke. It's a Michigan Senate primary,
not governor primary. John Platt is with us. He's the host of
Being Twitter on Platt podcast. Peter Hamby
I I'll just say just because you speak and say uh-huh every once
in a while, that doesn't mean you're reacting, okay? You don't
actually You could just stand there silently.
The You're not actually listening. So, don't Well, sorry, you're
not reacting. You're not transforming. You're going uh-huh, yeah,
okay, uh yep, yep, okay, uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh. That's not transforming.
once you a Zionist pig dog, he has called Hamas uh the Palestinian
resistance. He has justified October 7th and on and on and What
does his influence tell you about where the Democratic Party
stands today? And I guess Well, there's a lot of The thing is
that he is a representation
of the coalition that's being built that is anti-American,
anti-Christian, and anti-white. That's basically what he is.
I mean
I might not even disagree with that. Is
Like if you are anti-Christian
as in you think Christian Zionism is a heresy that needs to be
like brutally removed from your country on all levels, then sure.
If you think he's anti-white because he doesn't want to restrict
immigration such that whites remain a majority,
then that's okay. And then what? Anti-American such that you
will are willing to criticize the actions and decisions of America
on the global stage? Yeah, I think all three of those are good.
If
If that's what you mean when you label me anti-white, anti-Christian,
and anti-America,
then sign me the [__] up.
Yeah, that's that's perfect. I'm down for all of those if that's
what you mean. I mean, he's going to push for and advocate for
things that will work against those things. Uh racial solidarity
against white people, religious solidarity against Christianity,
and ideological solidarity against capitalism.
By the way, you are Canadian. Yeah, no
I already hate America. I already I changed my vote my own in
my own election because America.
So, I can be here happily. Yeah, you're right. and Western thought.
That's what's going to happen. And the thing is that a lot of
people don't want to say this this way. You're Christian now?
I'm not Christian, but I want to live in a Christian country.
Does that make sense? And culturally, I think that there are
a lot of people that are not really Muslims, but they're culturally
Muslims, right? They practice Ramadan, they uh you know, like
maybe they pray once or twice a day, and you know, maybe they
don't eat pork, but they don't go to the mosque every every week
or anything else. Like there's obviously very clearly a massive
difference there.
Despite those comments or because of those comments? I think
it's uh despite those comments a little bit. I mean, back to
your first question, what it says about the party, I think Dr.
Abdul Sayed is looking for a lane in a three-way primary. He's
slightly behind in the polling. And like a lot of Democrats and
a lot of progressives after the 2024 election wants to connect
with young people, connect with young men, go into the manosphere,
go into the podcast space. It just so happened Oh, by the way,
I will say I've no problem curbing immigration if you have economic
concerns. If you're trying to do it for specific economic concerns.
There's a way you can discuss immigration that lets me know you're
not a racist and you have legitimate concerns, right? But for
the people who are like, "No, we need to maintain this white
majority." Yeah, I don't care about you. Shut up. Shut up. Hasan
[__] is aligned with a lot of Dr. Abdul Sayed's views
on healthcare, on taxing the rich and billionaires, etc. He is
a Bernie, AOC, Zoran guy. But with that, he has a long reputation
of saying all of the things you just played
I was just talking to you before the the segment. I mean, I think
it is a risk for for Abdul Sayed to have him It's not because
it's the same It's the same audience of people. It's really not
for that guy. I mean, it's the same people. It's an obvious risk,
but he is grasping for votes in a crowded three-way primary in
a state, Michigan, which you remember from 2024, both in the
primary Democratic primary and the general election, has a lot
of Arab and Muslim voters in outside of Detroit and
Um economies of scale is a good reason to have immigration, but
and Zortician, I don't know how you're going to explain this.
Economies of scale clearly don't work
in terms of raising the standard of living or the wages of lower
class, low education, low skill workers.
like immigration has been used in the United States to suppress
wage growth amongst low skill workers for decades.
Obviously true.
Totally, completely, and entirely very
So, if you if you don't like that, if you don't like your labor
force having their wages suppressed, then I mean, hey, I don't
know. Maybe maybe you should be a little more against immigration,
full immigration. born in Dearborn Heights, and Democrats have
been suffering there. And I think he's trying to grab onto them.
He's doing rallies at Michigan and Michigan State. So, he's trying
to go after young >> Well, Dearborn is another example
of them trying to create a racial coalition
and a religious coalition, and then vote and make decisions based
off of that. I think this is the this is the
like this is the common thread between all of these things. It's
so obviously the case and and it's so bad over there that they
Is the populace brain rot that J Talk still has? No, it's not.
It's obviously true. You can't have that kind of immigration
without being able to tax those companies. You have to be able
to tax those companies like
Such that the profits feed back into the government and they
can take care of those people who are like struggling on those
wages.
But you you'll never get that. So >> worried about talking
about the good thing that the Ayatollah Khamenei is dead. This
is the guy in Iran that systematically killed thousands of his
own people and has oppressed them for nearly 50 years. Well,
not him, but you know, the regime has.
You know, this is like it it should be the easiest decision.
Yeah, you could do you could do labor you could do labor protections.
Dude, if you force all fruit companies, all fruit picking
like anyone who's exporting a ton of fruit out of California,
let's say.
You force them all to pay the actual minimum wage there. Those
companies would all go bankrupt.
Like immediately overnight. decision of your life and why is
it not an easy decision? Well, it's because you brought a bunch
of radical Muslims into the country that agree with them. That's
the reason why and I think it's obvious that's the problem and
it's a huge
One thing I do want to point out Jake that you said in the intro
that he's not a household name the speaking with American men
project which was launched to study men by Democrats after Oh,
yeah, [laughter] that go. 2024
Not so >> Hasan Piker's name among young men. He's not
well known at all. About half of young people don't know who
he is. And then his favorability he's negative 9%. He's underwater
with favs. Only 20% of young men have a favorable opinion of
Hasan [__] and that's why I say is it worth the gamble?
Interesting. And joining me now is the Wall Street Journal op-ed
that I talked about the think tank Third Way. They wrote >> Uh-huh.
We're all for a big tent, but the Democratic Party needs to draw
a line in the sand. Hasan [__] and his fellow haters
belong on the other side. >> Yeah. Donny O'Sullivan asked
[__] to respond to critics who call him anti-Semitic.
He quoted a few things that [__] had said especially
a Zionist dog or Zionist pig. I think the actual quote was Zionist
pig dog, whatever that means. Here is Piker's response. I've
spent Does Asmongold
comment on this? He knows he can't comment on the anti-Semitic
language,
He knows he can't admit that Hasan's an anti-He can't say Hasan's
an anti-Semite for that because all of the people around him
would be like a thousand times worse anti-Semites if he allowed
that. So, he's just going to sit here and go, yeah, okay. Yeah,
okay. Right? >> professional media far beyond that combating
anti-Semitism. I've been docked. Did you ban the people that
were spamming hearts for the manifesto
of the person that murdered two Israeli
in cold blood? Did you ban them in the in your your long career
of Why would you? That manifesto was really well written and
and struck at something. You could say you could literally just
say you can't raise and I think Hasan did. You can't go to violence
because of that. But the idea the ideas that guy was exposing
were
Totally correct.
Those the ideas that that guy was exposing in that manifesto
everything short of saying I want to go and and do violence because
of this was all correct. It was an entirely correct manifesto.
Anybody wants to jump on a call and read it with me? Okay? You
can come read it with me. Explain to me what you find actually
wrong about that manifesto at any level at any level other than
well, I think I can go to violence now. Why is violence never
correct? Because it works against your movement. One one it is
morally wrong to hurt other people to gain political to to move
forward your political goals. It is just inherently wrong. It
is morally wrong to forward your political goals through violence
unless you're Unless there's like a
present and immediate danger that needs to be averted. You know,
like well swatted by neo-Nazis for my consistent advocacy against
anti-Semitism. I just also happen to be an about anti-Zionist.
I believe Zionism is a very racist ideology. It's a The broad
argument of that manifesto was that if people make decisions
in government
and are going to act like they are not culpable for the decisions
at all. They're going to lean back into some broader like blob
and say, well, it was the blob's fault. No, you can hold them
responsible for those decisions. And the example he gives is
some general from Vietnam who did a bunch of war crimes or Korea.
I can't even remember somewhere in Southeast Asia. Okay? Some
guy was on a cruise and some dude was harassing him and going
like, you're a monster. You're a war criminal. You're a disgusting
piece of You're a disgusting piece of [__] And that
was awesome. That's awesome. Yeah, if that guy is a disgusting
piece of [__] let him hear it. Just don't actually
physically assault him. Don't actually which by the way that
that is where the story goes. I I believe I believe they get
into a scuffle cuz the general didn't the military guy didn't
like being told that and they get into a scuffle and the guy
who's calling him a piece of [__] threw that overboard.
See you later, General. Have some fun in the water.
Which is very funny. I think that's where the story goes. I think
if I remember correctly.
But um probably don't assault that guy if if if the guy who's
yelling at him started the fight too, that would be bad. But
I'm just saying like I don't mind the idea that you let that
guy know, I know who you are. I know who you are and I'm not
going to forget.
I think that's important. I think that's good. ethno-religious
supremacist ideology and it's the underpinning ideology that
has caused the genocide of
in the hands of Israel and also the United States. >> I
wonder what Hamas thinks about other
I want Why would that matter? wonder, you know, like if Hamas
was in control, do you think that there'd be any Jews? Um
If Hamas was in control of Israel?
No, I'm guessing there would be a problem for Jews in Israel.
These two groups hate each other. But why why is that something
that has to be avoided at all costs? Right? We can't have Hamas
in control, but people with an equal and equivalent ideology
on the other side are in control and absolutely devastating the
lives the lives and livelihoods of all the people in Gaza.
And that's fine.
I'm saying I don't want people in control. I don't want that
country run in a way where one group totally oppresses and and
destroys the live the the lives and happiness of the other
That's what I don't want.
Why are we acting like either side is good and aren't doing that
to the other? I don't know.
Uh goodbye.
Yeah, I wonder guys. Oh, wow, it's a big
Jews of America.
Mhm. Jonah, there's a lot to unpack there. What's your response?
Yeah, I mean what what [__] does that a lot of people
of his ilk do is they try to inoculate themselves against claims
of hatred by pointing it out in places that aren't them. He he's
he's been very clear pointing things out on the right. Oh, that's
anti-Semitism.
These are the tropes they use and then he'll use the exact same
tropes and just sub for Israel which is the place where all collectively
have a connection to and is the homeland where more than 50 >> Isn't
it crazy that
they can't even have one country?
Some
that's the size of New Jersey, Israel.
>> Dude, how are the how are the talking points so consistent?
There are 40 Muslim majority countries. Are you telling me the
Jews can't have one majority country?
I'm just telling you that it seems like countries that have a
like a
government and society seem like an extreme
threat to civilian life in countries surrounding them and I think
it's dangerous for them to have even one. Yes. They're it's an
extreme threat. It's extremely dangerous. It's extremely
Wait, he didn't say that? Hold on, watching you back. You You
understand they're not allowed to have one. You understand that
it's the talking point, right? That he's doing. He's doing the
consistent talking point. Can't even have one? The Muslims get
so many. Americans get so many. Catholics get so many. Christians
get so many. Can't have one?
That's what he's doing. You just don't recognize it. They can't
even have that.
I mean, bro, think about like goddamn.
People are just not having it.
Just let him Yeah, just let him have it, man. Goddamn.
percent of Jews on planet Earth live. So, it's not >> Right.
He would never say Jews control the media, but Israel controls
the
>> The 110th
country is going to be Israel.
>> Oh my god.
>> Right. The the Jews didn't pull us into the war with
Iran and control the American government, but Israel does. >> he's
able to sort of get away with some of this stuff in these subtle
ways when really his impact is just as harmful as any out and
out anti-Semite. Just he's got a different name and he comes
from a different wing of politics. It's interesting um Politico
asked a bunch of Democratic politicians running for president
or might who might run for president. It's pretty simple. If
you can't unequivocally condemn a group of people that are openly
advocating for the extermination of a race of people, then you
have a problem. It's very simple. Like Hamas and and Hezbollah
and the Houthis and the Iran government, the IRGC, these are
radical genocidal organizations that will try to not only purge
their own people, but then also go out and purge non-believers
that are outside of their own community as well. If you can't
unequivocally condemn that, then you've got a big problem. You've
got a huge problem. It's such an obvious reality in Israel, isn't
it? You can condemn Israel, too. You can say Israel's bad, too.
But if you don't have those other ones on the list, then I think
that you've obviously got a bias, don't you? It's totally fine
for you to condemn Israel. That's totally okay.
would ever do his podcast. And the the only two thinking about
possibly running for president, Rahm Emanuel
and Josh Barro, both suggested that they might be willing to.
I think this gets to something important with this debate in
Michigan. It's different to go on to his podcast and joust over
ideas. I think seeing Josh Shapiro and Hasan [__]
on his Twitch stream would be fascinating. I think Josh Shapiro
is smart and they would have a spirited debate, as they say in
politics. The difference is going out to campaign with somebody,
and the candidate uh it's implicitly endorsing his views or suggesting,
"Why don't you come to Michigan and campaign with me?" That's
the difference. I think candidates should be able to go on to
podcasts with people who disagree with them. Um but yeah, I mean
the politics >> he's right about that, there being a And
it's true. The factors here
the more Democrats engage with influencers heading into 2028,
they're going to have to confront some views and the things they
might have said in the past. Quick one sentence. Yes, it's true.
I mean, yeah. And and a lot of creators, the thing is that like
whenever you do a show on TV, you're live for like an hour. Whenever
somebody live streams, they're live every day for like 6 hours.
So, the probability that somebody says something that's bad is
like extremely high. Like basically anybody who ever talks about
social issues on the internet in an unscripted live format has
thousands of clips, at least hundreds of clips, of them saying
something that in a vacuum, and sometimes even objectively, sounds
really bad. Like this is just the reality of having long-form
talk radio,
That is actually true. It's nice of him to include that context
in here.
That's not to say it absolves like anybody saying something that's
like way out of pocket. But when you do talk for like 6 to 8
hours a day, every single
about, yeah, a lot of like different sensitive issues, you are
absolutely going to say some out of pocket and it doesn't really
have any, you know, that's why if you were trying to be genuine,
what you would do is you try to get like a broad base of what
a stream is like.
So, that is totally true. But if you don't get like a broad base
of what the stream is like actually like, you're just sort of
lying. You're grabbing a clip and trying to say, "Well, this
is who Hasan is." Like no, that's obviously not who Hasan is.
Come on, man. Come on, man. >> And you're going to say
things that, you know, out of context might sound really bad,
and some He's talking about regretting his F-slurs. The I think
the times I've used the F-slurs are the only time it's been appropriate
for me to use a slur on this
I can think of two instances, and in both of those cases, they
were 100% warranted and 100% accurate. So,
absolutely 100% accurate. things that even in context sound bad
still. Final thoughts on this? You worried about the direction
of the Democratic >> I'm worried. I agree they should be
able to debate, but they have to come in clear-eyed and know
that they're there to debate and push back on these bad ideas,
not to get it chummy and have a a fun conversation. Thanks so
much for being here. Uh then there's the awk tweet, okay? We
got to we got to look at the awk tweet really quick cuz there
is a there's going to be a Wick tweet coming off of this that's
really good, too. So, Asmongold gives his take on the drama surrounding
Hasan and the Democratic Party. I do think he reps the more extreme
radical leftist view of the Democratic Party at odds with the
more status quo people. There's a coalition of people that will
try to make excuses for, allow, and then create inroads for Islamic
radical terrorism, extremism, sorry. There will never be a time
where Hasan will side with America against radical Islam. Uh-huh.
Was the Aiden one justified, too? I don't remember calling Aiden
that. No, I wouldn't say it was justified if it was if there
was an Aiden one. I don't recall this.
I can't remember it, so no, I don't stand by that one if I said
it. I don't remember it. Anyway, anyway, on to the Wick So, Wick
had to come out and
"When Asmongold is right, he is right. So, broadly, that entire
segment from Asmongold is awesome. We love it. There's a coalition
of people who are trying to help Hasan the Hunt infiltrate and
be normalized within the Dem Party.
That's not what Asmongold's talking about at all. It's not. That's
not what Asmongold is talking about, man. All of those people,
by the way, that Wick wants to to network with, Wick wants to
be a part of, Asmongold's talking about Kyle Kulinski. Asmongold
talked about Crystal Ball. Asmongold talked about everybody around
Hasan.
All of these people. Wick is not Well, unless Wick is now going
to say, "Actually, you know, we need to cut Kyle Kulinski and
Crystal Ball. They need to be out of the Democratic Party."
Um Enemy Charlie needs to be out of the Democratic Party. Hold
on. Where is this Enemy Charlie tweet? Wick has come out and
explained that he absolutely finds Enemy Charlie disgusting.
She is a disgusting extremist radical freak that needs to be
denou- Oh, he Right, he streams with her all the time, right?
Enemy Charlie repost, "I want the US to lose the war. For the
sake of liberation and decoloni- decolonization, it must lose.
For the sake of humanity, we must lose. The best outcome for
the US results in ecocide and multiple
And it looks like Em- Enemy Charlie's on the Hasan side.
By the way, if it were put to Wick in this precise way, Wick
would flip instantly. Wick would totally abandon everything he
stands for to be like, "No, no, no, I love Enemy Charlie. I love
Enemy Charlie." The only way they justify hanging out with Charlie
and that Tilly person and any other
unfortunate I hate to say it attractive leftist woman is because
one, they're attractive, and two, they infantilize them and make
it seem like they're totally
You saw this multiple times from Erudite two nights ago when
they're talking about the soy pill stuff, right? When they're
talking to Soy Pill. Oh, well, the reason Charlie and like and
Tilly think this is cuz they're like really naive in their politics.
They're really shallow in their politics. They just don't really
know anything. They're kind of like really stupid. that will
will just We can bring on panels and say eye candy and they this
they're meant to be seen and not heard. It's uh I added maybe
a little bit at the end there, but it's all it's all Yeah, they
because they live in LA and they can't resist their social circle.
>> Dude, it's so funny, man.
Like some of the most misogynistic I've ever heard in my life.
Well, these young women don't know anything.
You added a lot? No, that is all implied by what I said. Okay,
not the part about
not the part about them being seen and not heard. But what she
legitimately said, I'll I'll actually quote. She said they're
too naive in their political ideology. They're in social groups
that don't let them see anything else, and if they just had somebody
to explain it to them, they would understand that Hasan is bad.
I added the Hasan is bad, but socialism is bad part, right?
That is infantilization. That is misogynistic. That is an actual
problem. You are saying that they're too dumb to actually know
what they're talking about. Okay? You are saying that. 100% you
are. Don't pretend otherwise. So, anyway, back to the back to
the Wick tweet. This would destroy our party and ensure right-wing
rule for a long, long time. We must fight against him and those
who normalize him as hard as we fight against MAGA. Yeah, these
people are
they've like no argument here at all.
I I'm sorry. If you pretend that Hasan is the same size of threat
as MAGA is, or that he's somehow going to get your party not
elected, Hasan is only going out with the like with left-wing
candidates, with like borderline like DemSoc candidates, right?
That El Sayed guy is in a competitive primary,
and it's just a primary.
Hasan is no threat to your party whatsoever in that primary.
Zero threat. But you're going to pretend he is because you want
to rally against him, because that's what gets you the most clicks
and views online. Which is I guess fine, technically, if you
were transparent about it. But that is the only reason you're
presenting this argument is cuz you will get donations and views
and clicks for presenting this argument this way and think and
presenting it as sincere. It's not sincere. Or I mean, maybe
you're sincerely I'm not sure which.
I'm really not sure which, man. If N C keeps bringing female
creators to Destiny after everything, she is actually Kindegarten
Maxwell. Well, well, well, well. Asmongold is just the other
side of the same coin, though. Yeah, no one's trying to insert
him into my party. LOL.
Based on post, I have to ask, "Who's paying you?" The third way
Dem leadership? Yes, more centrist businesses, business as usual
that got us to where we we are won't backfire in any way. Clown,
clown, clown. Your mom for services rendered. Your mom I Your
mom. I Your mom. I Your mom.
So cool.
Socialism is dumb. Dunking on dumb ideas gets clicks.
So, they're presenting they're presenting this as equivalently
threatening to MAGA.
Do you not think that is really
Is that not like clear grifting?
If you're just saying socialism is dumb, it's ineffective and
dumb, and it gets clicks. Is this not explicitly grifting? You
are presenting this as a real present threat, a real problem
for your
when MAGA is like an existential threat to your country. This
is clear grifting, right? Obvious grifting.
This is just clear grifting. Or explain to me why Hasan is as
big a threat. Explain to me how Hasan, when Hasan has for the
past couple years campaigned with people like AOC and Bernie
Sanders, like 4 years, 4 years, and it's not been the destruction
of the Dem party at all.
What now has changed such that oh, it's the destruction of the
Dem party if Hasan campaigns with one more person in a primary?
Anybody Can anyone explain it to me? Can anyone make this make
sense? It's just incredibly sad, man. It's incredibly sad, incredibly
transparent.
It's It's just It's depressing to look at, to be honest with
you. All I want or all I would want if I was an American voter,
okay? All I would want, the best thing in the world. Do you know
what it would be?
Anti-Zionist libs.
That's That's it. Anti-Zionist libs who are doing like abundance
policies, but they're like anti-Zionist.
How hard is that, man? How hard is it?
So So, it's impossible, apparently. Apparently, it's totally
impossible.
Even though that's where the whole party is, it's just impossible
to do. It's
hopefully Matt Iglesias wins on that
Okay. Let's see what else we got here. What else we got here?
Asman is right. Remember this jam?
There are plenty of gay and trans people. By the way, Iran is
actually weirdly very pro-trans,
but I'm sure that you probably didn't know that. Is this
Was Iran the country that was basically like if you're gay, we
we'll actually just transition you?
Is that like if you want to take your woman automatically, so
we'll transition
Is that Is that Iran? Am I making that up? There's some country
that that's the way they look at it. We're going to trans you
if you if you are gay. I don't think that's like pro-trans necessarily.
They're very homophobic, but they are They are They are very
pro-trans. A lot of A lot of cultures are actually very pro-trans,
way more than the United States of
>> I That's something else. That's like something else,
man, okay? That is something else. >> Maybe to a fault
at times, like Iran when they do forcible
Oh, wait. I mean, you look at like >> Oh, he is Oh, I see.
He is literally saying it. I I get it. He was trying to present
it in an edgy way.
in American culture, I think it's extremely popular. Norse culture,
I mean, you could say the same thing about [clears throat] Loki,
right? It's It's like the idea of Wait, is Asman Gold Krieg with
a
Why is Asman Gold Krieg I didn't realize this is the Asman Gold
Krieg combo.
He's just sitting there Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. >> is like super
super super old, like Shiva, right? Another good example. So,
I I think that that is There's a There's a concept of this third
gender in in in
Let's go. Oh, actually, the concept of transgenderism is multicultural
and and has a long and and a long and storied history on the
world. >> Thank you.
So, yeah.
that's an awesome clip. That's an awesome clip right there. That's
very funny. We do a little XQC react. If we speed through the
actual commentary from CNN, I'm sure there's only like 90 seconds
of XQC commentary in this >> [__] is thinking
about possibly running for president. Rahm Emanuel and Josh Shapiro
both suggested that they might be willing to. I think this gets
to something important with this debate in >> It's It's
It's all about what you're doing and the goals This is my my
personal opinion, okay? If If you say oh, dude, anti-Zionist
isn't anti-Semitic, whatever.
If If If somebody's using the method of of trying to portray
everything as anti-Zionist to have a goals that are anti-Semitic,
in my opinion, it's it's wrong. It's wrong. Is that why people
say oh, guys, uh will all lives What What's an anti-Semitic goal
Hasan has? What's an anti-Semitic goal that Hasan has is what
XQC's got to explain. What is the anti-Semitic goal that is that
is happening here? It's It's wrong. It's wrong. Is that why people
say oh, guys, will all lives matter? It's like, okay, I would
agree with this in general, but most people that say this [__]
most of them do it in a way to discredit Black Lives Matter [__]
It is what it is. And you can do do me all you want to, but it's
just a lot of people use it as a vehicle to go somewhere else.
So, when I see a bad actor that uses the vehicle, I call it out.
And I think it's not that bad. And that's it. To go on to Why?
I I would love Can XQC lay out his thoughts? I would love to
hear him lay out his thoughts on this. Why does he think that?
Why What is the anti-Semitic goal here? his podcast and joust
over ideas. I think seeing Josh Shapiro and Hasan [__]
on his Twitch stream would be fascinating. I think Josh Shapiro
is smart and they would have a spirited debate, as we say in
politics. The difference is going out to campaign with somebody,
and the candidate is implicitly endorsing his views or suggesting,
why don't you come to Michigan and campaign with me? That's the
difference. I think candidates should be able to go on to podcasts
with people who disagree with them. But yeah, I mean, the politics
of Israel heading
Was my goal to discredit the LGBT? Was my goal to be anti-gay,
whatever? Absolutely not. Like when when If you get a feel for
what somebody's doing, uh um then it's just it's just like a
reading game.
You didn't get that feel, though. That feel was programmed into
your brain by people who are like feeding you Like that That's
not your feel. Or you could explain it. But you're not going
to explain it. You're just going to say well, it's my feeling
that he does this. This This whole interview is really bad. I
was I was seeing if there's anything else. I don't think there's
very much else. I think that's it for that.